[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's dave lapham unrealism bengals
radio network analyst for over 30 years
bengals offensive tackle i think from 74
to 1983 he was uh on the 81 afc
championship team that beat the chargers
lost the super bowl to the 49ers he'll
be on the call the bengals and the
chiefs at arrowhead kickoff at 3 eastern
and
dave joins us once again
dave how's moral in cincinnati
man i'll tell you dan the city is off
the hook i mean they are going crazy i
remember you know playing in uh super
bowl 16 the 81 82 season that just the
community just went crazy same thing 80
89 for super bowl 23 but there was no
social media now with social media oh my
gosh man i mean it is
it is as crazy as it could be
is it joe burrows town
absolutely
absolutely i mean
uh joe barrow is the straw that stirs
the drink there is no question about
that and you know the thing about him
dan uh
unbelievable player obviously he's got
all these physical talents but his
mental and physical toughness is
something that the team's kind of
rallying around i mean he gets sacked
nine times
never cussed out any teammates uh you
know just gets up goes on to the next
play if it's a third down he walks off
goes off the field sits on the bench
grabs his computer puts on his headset
okay coaches let's forget about that how
do we get better we'll do the next
series
unravelable i mean you know just totally
composed uh he never flinches i mean
i've seen the great tom brady sack
himself after getting hit a few times
you know kind of cover up a little bit
joe burrow that's not in his dna and it
motivates and inspires his teammates
there's no doubt when did you realize
that maybe there was something special
about this team
you know i i think
the when joe came back early you know i
think before people thought he was going
to be able to come back and and played
from the beginning of the season on
early in training camp dan he was having
some claustrophobia issues you know
after having that knee ripped and have
to be reconstructed um when you get hit
and stacked in washington against the
redskins wait explain that
claustrophobia are you talking about in
the pocket that yeah because exactly the
surgery
yeah so so he gets ripped the washington
football team you know allen rips his
knee up and he has to have it
reconstructed so in the early stages of
training camp when he was in pass rush
situations he got a little a little bit
claustrophobic which is understandable
but man he once he broke through that
and he started right after the bye week
i think physically his knees started
feeling better because during the bye he
had more time to even increase the rehab
and he started feeling really good
physically after the bye and now
he doesn't even think about it i mean
he's extending plays running around
you know manipulating the pocket doing
all the things that he did and uh
even even last year when he played in
the 10 games he played in he just has it
you know i mean he has that it factor
and and you look at it dan there's their
their group of specialists
i mean the three wide receiver package
they put out there's as good as any in
the league when you talk about uh chase
higgins and and uh boyd then you have cj
zama complimentary guy at tight end and
then you have joe mixon it's pretty darn
good
they beat kansas city a couple of weeks
ago how do they beat kansas city this
time with what's at stake in kansas city
i think it has to be
like it was last time in january 2nd in
the regular season paul brown stadium
neither team turned the football over
they both played a clean game that way
but kansas city self-destructed with
penalty they had they have a punt return
nullified by a holding penalty
they had 10 penalties in the game
six of them resulted in first downs for
the bengals to continue drives and that
sort of thing so they self-destructed by
penalty
if uh if the chiefs bring their a game
and the bengals you know don't they're
in trouble if they both bring their a
game it's gonna be tough out there at
arrowhead uh this is the fourth straight
afc championship game that kansas city's
hosted in their last eight playoff games
they're seven and one it's a brutal
place to play a tough place to play so
you know you always strive to play the
perfect game they almost have to think
they got to play the perfect game and
think that kansas city might help them a
little bit somehow talking to dave
lapland former bengal offensive lineman
played in a super bowl and uh has been
with the bengals radio network for over
30 years i want to play a couple of
clips here um how do you feel about
listening to yourself
when you uh when you listen to these
highlights
yeah sometimes i shake my head yeah
there's no doubt
here's the interception to clinch the
wild card win over the raiders
fourth down and goal from the nine 17
seconds to go the play clock at three
shotgun snap car throws in the traffic
interceptions
how about that
where did bam bam bam come from dave
yeah well we just started uh whenever
there was a play that we felt was going
to be the clincher for the game
determine the game in the bengals favor
we started this little deal where you
know dan would say coffee nails and i
would just finalize it bam bam bam put
those coffee mails in the comments
here's evan mcpherson game-winning field
goal to win the divisional game
clark harris will snap it back to kevin
huber for the win the snap the put down
the swing of the right leg it's on its
way it is good
nails
bam bam bam that is unbelievable 54 and
52 at the gun that is unrealism right
there that's courtesy of wlw the bengals
radio network and then there's this one
we've had dave with joy and dave with
sorrow the bengals missing a field goal
in overtime versus the packers from
october of 2021
huber ready for the snap from clark
harris he extends the right hand catches
the ball puts it down the kick is on its
way it hits the upright and is no good
oh my gosh five
missed field goals unbelievable does
anybody want to win this football game
did anybody ever teach you about radio
how to do this
all i can say is uh john saller when i
first got the uh got the opportunity he
said you know this is local radio you
remember joe knocks off yeah with the
cincinnati reds and he said you know i
want you to do radio uh kind of like a
fan sitting at a bar with a bunch of
people and reacting like they would
react and like joe knocks on like okay
so i just started doing it that way now
you know i've done
network games for nfl and college
football and obviously it's a different
dynamic but that's what john sawler
wanted when i started doing local radio
with the cincinnati bengals
what do you make of that remember about
that super bowl that you played in
that we helped them
they were they were good enough to beat
us uh and we turned it over four times
and we had a goal line stand against us
they only turned it over once so in my
mind that goal line stand is equivalent
to a turnover it was a possession that
didn't end with a kick a punt extra
pointer field goal
so we had five of those
they had one we went minus four and we
lost by five points i mean if we don't
beat ourselves and put ourselves on our
schedule we might have a better shot
they were plenty good enough to beat us
without us helping them and we helped
them a ton
did you realize montana was montana back
then
knew that he had something special you
know and and i i think joe burrow and
montana are very similar in that you
know both don't have howitzers hanging
off of their right shoulder but they're
plenty good enough plenty of arm
strength to make every throw
unbelievably accurate can put it in a
porthole not a window a porthole even
and and that and then they can extend
and create get out of pocket when when
joe borrowed through that touchdown pass
to tyler boyd in cincinnati in the
playoffs
um i thought right back to joe montana
to dwight clark joe montana out of
pocket four gone out of bounds
throughout to the back line of the end
zone dwight clark coming across the end
zone tyler boyd was going the other way
but it's the same type of dynamic and
and uh both highly intelligent
quarterbacks tremendous football iq
they have uh you know just great
leadership qualities both tough as nails
i think there's a lot of similarities
between those two guys i think you
should change the spelling of your name
it should be dave l-a-p-b-a-m
bam bam
just you know maybe just for the
football season dave i don't know check
with your family but
i'll tell you you are a marketing guru
man thank you
that's darn good uh you're fast have fun
this weekend dave great to catch up with
you again and uh who day
good they dan and uh i'll tell you you
got you got a ton of fans everywhere but
as you know in uh in southwest ohio you
are the man thank you buddy that's uh
not officially the man just letting
people know unofficially dave lapham
although i always hear from my friends
uh and they'll go
are you on the bengals bandwagon i go no
i i would love for them to win because
of the story and the people in
cincinnati but that's not the business
i'm in anymore i'm not i'm not able to
be a fan and do my job correctly